المترجم: Nawal Sharabati
المدقّق: Nada Qanbar
صباح الخير أيها الجمهور،
ما هي أخباركم وأحوالكم.
أنا عالية سليمان، مديرة وحدة
التسويق والاتصال في مؤسسة خريطة التحرش
وأنا سعيدة بوجودي معكم اليوم،
وأشكرُ جامعة الأهرام الكندية على استضافتها
في الحقيقة، أنا شغوفة جدًا بموضوع
التحرش الجنسي،
لكن في البداية والنهاية، فإنني أنتمي
إلى الأهرام حيثُ كنتُ أعمل فيها،
وأنا سعيدة بوجود مثل هذا المؤتمر الكبير،
وإنها لفرصة جيدة خاصة أن اليوم
هو 8 مارس/آذار، يوم المرأة العالمي،
فكل عام والمرأة المصرية بخير
قبل أن أبدأ في الحديث، أودُ التحدث سريعًا
عن تجربة شخصية حدثت معي،
وهذه التجربة جعلتني، حتى قبل
أن أنتمي إلى فريق مؤسسة خريطة التحرش،
أبحثُ وأحاول فهم
ما هي أسباب التحرش الجنسي؟
ولماذا يحدثُ؟ وهل هناك مشكلة ما؟
ولماذا الانتشار الكبير لهذه الظاهر سواء
في القاهرة أو محافظات الجمهورية؟
أحد الأمور الذي جعلني أفكرُ بهذا الأمر،
كنتُ يومًا ما أتحدثُ إلى مجموعة
من زملائي الصحفيين عن التحرش الجنسي
وقالت لي إحدى الصحفيات، "لا يحقُ لك الحديث
عن التحرش الجنسي بسبب عدم ارتدائك الحجاب"،
كنتُ أرتدي الحجاب كما أنا الآن،
رقبتي ظاهرة وشعري مُغطى.
وأضافت، "يؤدي يظهور الرقبة إلى التحرش بي،
وأنه إذا تم ذلك، وذهبتُ للتبليغ،
فلن يهتم بي أحد، لأن طريقة ارتدائي
للحجاب ليست صحيحة."
فصدمتُ من كلامها، وأجبتها،
"هل معقول كلامك، كل الأمر رقبة ظاهرة،"
فردت، "أعرفُ أنه كلام صادم
خاصة أنني غير محجبة،
وأنا أيضًا لا أستطيع الذهاب للتبليغ
عن تحرش جنسي."
كان هذا الحدث قريبًا بعد أن تكلم الناس
عن علاقة التحرش بلباس المرأة.
وأنه ليس هناك علاقة بين لباس المرأة
والتحرش حيث يتعرضُ المنقبات أيضًا إليه.
لقد بدأت بهذه الكلام لأن هناك علاقة
بين الحادث ومبررات التحرش الجنسي.
نلاحظُ مثل هذه الحوادث من خلال عملنا
في مؤسسة خريطة التحرش من عام 2010
وهدفنا العمل للحد من حوادث التحرش الجنسي
في مجتمعاتنا المصرية.
جعلتني هذه الحادثة أن أنضم إلى المجموعة
التي تدرسُ الموضوع بكل جوانبه،
وتعملُ الفرق تطوعيًا، فالمؤسسة قائمة
على التطوع، ونحاول فهم المشكلة لحلها.
هل سنقضي على مشكلة التحرش الجنسي
بين ليلة وضحاها؟ طبعًا، كلا!
فالحادثة التي ذكرتها سابقًا،
تجعلنا نقفُ مع أنفسنا، ونفكرُ بشكلٍ إيجابي
ونتساءل لمذا يلومُ البعض المرأة
على طريقة ارتدائها لملابسها،
ولماذا يفكر بعض الناس
أن التحرش هو نتيجة لذلك؟
يأتي فهم وحل هذه المشكلة تدريجيًا،
لذلك سأقوم سريعًا بشرح هدف ورؤية
خريطة التحرش من التغييرات التي تحدث،
فهي تقومُ على أساس مراحل التحول،
بمعنى أننا سنعملُ مع مكانٍ واحد،
مثل جامعة أو شركة ما، ونؤكدُ أن التحرش
غير مقبول نهائيًا.
وسيكون هناك عواقب اجتماعية وقانونية
لمن يقوم بالتحرش،
نتكلمُ هنا عن وجود لوائح موضوعة
من قبل المسؤولين لمنع التحرش الجنسي،
وبنفس الوقت اعتباره جريمة يعاقب عليها
القانون المصري بكل أنواعه،
بما فيه التحرش اللفظي أيضًا.
ومن المهم أن يدرك الناس وجود مثل هذه
القوانين عن طريق توعيتهم من قبل مؤسستنا.
وبهذا، وعلى المدى الطويل، يفهم الناس
معنى التحرش الجنسي عن طريق التوعية،
ويمكنُ أن يتصدوا له في حالة حدوثه أمامهم
في المدرسة، أو الجامعة، أو الشركة.
سيأخذ هذا العمل وقتًا طويلًا،
لكننا نستطيع الآن ملاحظة وقياس التغيير،
على المدى القصير، علينا العمل
في المكان المتواجدين فيه،
على سبيل المثال، يوجد في جامعة القاهرة
سياسة موجودة، ووحدة العنف والتحرش الجنسي،
ويوجد أيضًا أشخاص يعملون من خلال الوحدة
على توعية الناس بمعنى التحرش الجنسي،
خاصةً وأن فكرة مبررات التحرش الجنسي
هي جزء مهم جدًا،
من حيثُ طريقة ارتداء المرأة لملابسها،
وكيف كانت تصرفاتها عندما حدث التحرش.
فبدلًا أن يكون التدخل ايجابيًا،
تصلنا بلاغات في معظمها يقع اللوم
على المتحرش،
وفكرة المبررات التي تقال للمتحرش بها:
لا بأس فهو مثل والدك، أو مثل أخوك،
أو لا بأس فهو ما زال صغيرًا،
أو أنظري أولًا إلى ملابسك قبل أن تشتكي.
بشكل عام، يدينُ دومًا التدخل
من تعرض للتحرش الجنسي،
فالتدخل الإيجابي مهم،
فهناك نظرية التدخل المهمة جدًا،
وبإمكانكم قراءة المزيد عنها خلال الدراسات،
والحملات السابقة عن التحرش الجنسي.
وفي حالة حدوث تصرف خاطىء، يبدأ التدخل
من خلال شخص واحد، ثم يتبعه البقية،
مثلاً، لو تعرضتُ لسرقة في الشارع،
وبدأت أقول بأن شخصًا سرقني،
فسنرى أن شخصًا أو اثنين ركضا وراءه.
زاد التدخل فيما يخص التحرش الجنسي،
وأصبح هناك تغيير ملموس منذ عام 2010.
لكن تختلفُ السرقة عن التحرش،
حيث لن يقال لأحدكم،
"أنت السبب لأنك كنت تسيرين وحقيبتك مفتوحة،
أو عليك الانتباه أكثر"،
نريدُ أن يصبح التحرش الجنسي غير مقبول
أو مسموح كمعيار وسلوك اجتماعي،
وهذه هي "نظرية التغيير" المأخوذه من الكتاب
الذي نستوحي أفكارنا منه،
فيما يخصُ نقطة التحول التي تعتبر التحرش
جريمة من قبل المجتمع بشكل عام،
وليس من قبل القانون فقط.
سيحدثُ ذلك على المدى البعيد،
حيث نقومُ حاليًا بتدريب الأشخاص،
ونعملُ مع الوحدات المجتمعية في الجامعات
والشركات وما إلى ذلك.
ونعملُ أيضًا على قضية التدخل من قبل الناس
عندما يحدثُ التحرش أمامها.
سأقومُ سريعًا بشرح طبيعة عملنا في خريطة
التحرش منذ أن بدأت عام 2010 إلى الآن.
بدأنا أولًا في فكرة الخريطة لتحديد
التحرش الجنسي نظرًا لأهميته في 2010،
حيث كان يشيرُ الإعلام إلى التحرش الجنسي
وكأنه مجرد مُعاكسة لا غير،
وكان يقلل من حجم الظاهرة، وأن التحرش
لا يحصل في مجتمعاتنا.
ولا يعاني المجتمع المصري من هذه المشكلة،
فكنا نرفضُ الاعتراف بوجود هذه المشكلة.
فكانت النساء اللواتي يتم التحرش بهن،
لا يستطعن التوجه إلى مكان مناسب للتبليغ.
لذا، أوجدنا طريق التبليغ في خريطة التحرش،
وما هي الأماكن التي يتم فيها التحرش الجنسي
وما هي أنواع التحرش، ومن غير أن يتم
تحديد شخصية اسم المتحرش به أو بها.
وكان ذلك مهمًا في عام 2010،
لأن التحرش الجنسي كان من المحرمات.
ولكن حاليًا بدأت الفتيات التبليغ
عن التحرش من خلال وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اصبحنا نعلمُ بوقوع حوادث التحرش الجنسي،
وبدأ يعي المجتمع بهذه المشكلة.
وفي شهر آيار/مايو، طالبت مجموعة شركة ما
بفصل بعض الموظفين بسبب تحرشهم.
هذا مثال على الأمور التي نعملُ عليها،
وكما تعملُ المدارس والجامعات الآمنة
على تطبيق سياسة لمنع التحرش الجنسي،
حيثُ تبدأ بالتوعية،
وإقامة الندوات لشرح معنى
وأنواع التحرش الجنسي.
يوجد في جامعة القاهرة وحدة التحرش الجنسي،
وبالمشاركة معهم أقمنا سياسة لمنعه أيضًا.
كما قمنا بنفس الشيء في جامعة بني سويف،
وتطور الأمر هناك حيث يعتقد الناس
بأن التحرش يحدثُ في القاهرة فقط،
إنه يحدثُ في جميع محافظات الجمهورية.
وأقامت جامعة بني سويف وحدة لمناهضة
العنف والتحرش الجنسي.
كما أننا نعملُ في جامعات أخرى
في مختلف محافظات الجمهورية.
كما أردنا الوصول إلى عدد أكبر من الناس
فبدلًا من الحديث عن التحرش الجنسي
بألفاظ غير مناسبة وتضخيم الموضوع،
يمكننا الحديث بلغة بسيطة مفهومة.
لذلك، قررنا الوصول إلى العشوائيات،
والحديث مع الناس هناك،
والتفاعل معهم
عن طريق ما يسمى "المسرح التفاعلي".
بمعنى محاكاة ما يحصل في الشارع المصري
عند التحرش الجنسي،
وما هو دور كل شخص عند التحرش الجنسي،
مثلًا دور الرجل العجوز، أو الفتاة، وهكذا.
أما بالنسبة إلى الشركات الآمنة،
فسنطبق نظرية التغيير التي تحدثنا عنها،
سنتواجد في المكان الذي سنعملُ فيه
مثل الجامعة أو الشركة،
فستقوم الشركة الآمنة بتطبيق سياسة مناهضة
للتحرش الجنسي،
عن طريق وضع آليات واضحة وصريحة،
مثل ما هي الإجراءات التي ستتخذ ضد المتحرش،
هل سيتمُ فصله عن العمل،
أو سيتمُ الخصم من راتبه
وسيكون هناك شخص مسؤول
عن التواصل مع المتحرش.
ومن الأمور التي اتبعناها لنشر التوعية،
قمنا بعمل وسيلة للتواصل الإجتماعي
في شهر يوليو/تموز الماضي لتوعية الناس
بحدوث التحرش الجنسي في الأماكن العامة،
خاصةً وأن الناس كانت تعتقد بعدم حدوثه،
أو أنه يحدث بشكل جزئي،
أو أنه يحدث بين العمال في المصانع فقط.
إنه يحدثُ في كل الطبقات: أغنياء وفقراء،
شركات محلية أو متعددة الجنسيات،
وشركات صغيرة أو كبيرة،
ومن المهم أن نعرف بذلك.
فقمنا بإطلاق حملة لتعريف الناس
بأن التحرش الجنسي من الأولويات،
وأنه ينبغي الانتباه إليه في الشركة،
أو مكان العمل،
وأن التحرش يؤثر على نشاط وأداء الشخص،
ومن الأمور المضحكة أو التحديات
التي حصلت معنا حيث تواصلنا مع أحد
مقاهي الإنترنت الشهيرة،
وكانت إحداهن قد تعرضت للتحرش الجنسي،
وتواصلنا مع الناجية،
وكنا نريدُ معرفة ما هي الإجراءات
التي اتخذت ضد المتحرش،
فسألنا المتحرش بها عن ذلك،
وقالت بأنها اشتكت الأمر إلى المدير،
وقام المدير بمكافأتها بعصير فواكه
على حساب المحل.
وانتهى الموضوع على ذلك،
وكأنه يقول لها،
"اشربي العصير وانسي الموضوع".
يدعو الأمر إلى الضحك، وحاولنا أن نضحك،
لكنه حادثُ يدل على استخفاف الناس بالتحرش.
وأن التعرض للتحرش الجنسي ليس بالمشكلة.
سنتحدث سريعًا عن موضوع آخر له علاقة
بمبررات التحرش الجنسي،
وفكرة الحملة التي أطلقناها عام 2013
حول مبررات التحرش الجنسي التي ذكرتها سابقا
بمعنى إذا كان هناك علاقة
بين لباس المرأة والتحرش الجنسي،
فلماذا تتعرض المنقبة له؟
وإذا كان هناك علاقة بين الفقر والتحرش،
فلماذا يتم التحرش بالأغنياء؟
وإن كان سببه تأخر سن الزواج،
فلماذا يتم التحرش بفتيات بعمر 8 سنوات؟
دفعتنا هذه المبررات للتفكير المستمر،
وأنها وراء تقبل المجتمع للتحرش الجنسي.
أطلقنا حملة أخرى بعنوان "المتحرش" لتوعية
الناس بوجود قانون يمنع التحرش بكل أنواعه.
كانت الحملة عبر وسائل التواصل الإجتماعي
تتحدث عن وجود التحرش في المدارس والجامعات.
ولكي لا أطيل عليكم كثيرًا، بشكل عام،
فقد حصل تغيير في خريطة التحرش من عام 2010
إلى الآن بشأن التغيير في موضوع
التحرش الجنسي، لم يعد من المحرمات،
أصبحنا نتحدث عنه في وسائل الإعلام،
والجامعات، وأصبحت الجامعات بشكل عام
تتخذ خطوات للتصدي للتحرش الجنسي.
لا تفكر بالموضوع وكأنك الوحيد المسؤول
عن التصدي للتحرش،
حصل تغيير على المستوى الفردي حيث
أصبح الفرد يتدخل عندما يحدث أمامه
التحرش الجنسي سواء كان رجلًا أو امرأة.
فنحنُ لسنا سيدات فقط، إنها مجموعة
من المتطوعين من النساء والرجال.
وينبغي علينا التدخل لأن التحرش الجنسي
يضرُ المجتمع ككل.
وسيؤثر ذلك عامةً على المجمتمع ككل،
وعلينا عدم الاستخفاف بالتصرف الفردي.
شكرًا لكم.
(تصفيق)